hi i'm dave chang i'm the host of the
new netflix series breakfast lunch and
dinner today i'm going to be tasting
three dishes and i'm going to try to
guess which well-known chef is behind
the dish i am going to try to literally
guest blind
so
i'm i'm thinking i'm gonna do pretty
badly
i've never really been a breakfast guy
until the birth of my son
and now i make breakfast all the time
and we eat breakfast as a family but
up until
now what 41 plus years later i only ate
breakfast if i was
having a fun night the night before i
have no idea what's here and we'll see
what happens
i can tell you right now i've never had
this for breakfast
it is some kind of breakfast bread
pudding type thing i see a peach or
nectarine with raspberries
and
could be cornmeal i can tell you right
now this is not what i would eat for
breakfast i'm not like a kind of sweet
waffle kind of person
i'm trying to think of who it isn't
number one
this is not a chef from california or
the west coast this is not a chef from
the south it's definitely not a french
chef
it's not a chef from
europe
it's someone that makes american comfort
food it's like rachel ray sandra lee
or
someone on the food network my final
guess is sandra lee but we're going to
find out the end
lunch is a meal that constantly changes
as i get older it's now trying to be a
little bit more healthier so it's
whatever to get me to dinner so it's a
salad or a sandwich
and i couldn't have been more wrong this
is lunch
looks like we have a bowl of bacon
macaroni the only thing i'm happy about
it's not lobster or mac and cheese
something you see too much of i guess
looks like it was made a traditional way
with a bechamel and then mounted with
cheese and
the fact that bacon has added to this
also means this is a unorthodox approach
to
to cooking i think a chef like jessica
coslow is not making this i'm also going
to say this is someone that is
self-taught this is someone that's also
american a taste
i think i have an idea
so i think it's someone that is
thinking outside the box
my final pick even if it's not right
it's right aisha curry
dinner is uh the meal of the day for me
this being sort of fall late fall
maybe in getting colder i'd want a stew
or some kind of soupy thing with a bowl
of rice that's something i we did at
home i'm gonna bet money that this is a
meat loafy chicken pot pie e thing
i don't know who the hell made this
what's in it
this kimchi
you know for a second i had to go
through the data banks be like is this a
recipe that i would have made
would a korean person have made this no
i want options i want options i need a
lifeline
i know i said it could have been a
korean person i see
three people two of them are
koreans
you have sheng yun from father's office
you have roy choi from
kogi
and you have naked chef
i think this is jamie oliver dish but
the reality is it could be roy choi
hold on i gotta figure this out
and what's in it cheese
mayonnaise
a cabbage
this is a roy choi jamie oliver wouldn't
have used
uh cilantro and he would not have gone
the extra mile to put sesame oil in the
mayonnaise so this is my good friend roy
choice
hot dog
all right so i have the three correct
answers in front of me for my guesses of
breakfast lunch and dinner for breakfast
i chose
sandra lee
right
for lunch i chose aisha curry
mother
[Music]
ice curry
[Music]
for dinner i chose
roy choi
and his cookie dogs by roy choi
all right
perfect score
thanks for having me guys this was my uh
my attempt to guess breakfast lunch and
dinner we have a show called breakfast
lunch and dinner on netflix check it out
and um yeah this is this is how you do
it you guess a perfect score
[Music]
you